wäre ein frieden denn ein unterwerfung
frieden es kommt drauf an wie so ein
kompromiss aussehen also ich glaube auch
dass einem bestimmten zeitpunkt ist
natürlich verhandlung geben wird und das
ist eine hoch schwierige und auch hoch
emotionale frage für das ganze land denn
man muss sich das so vorstellen
ich würde dem widersprechen was frau
wagenknecht gesagt hat oder ich habe
zumindest in den eindruck den sie
vermittelt haben dass die meisten
ukrainer sagen sie wollen dass der krieg
sofort auf natürlich nicht um jeden
preis aber das ist natürlich mein leben
natürlich wollen die menschen dass der
krieg auch wenn nur es gibt eine weitere
komponente sind mittlerweile so viele
menschen gestorben
ist sind so viele orte
total zerstört worden dass die stimmung
die ich dort in der ukraine wahrnehme so
ist dass man sagt wir werden nicht
aufgeben ich hatte damals erwartet zu
beginn des krieges dass die moral
sich eher nach unten entwickeln würde
also dass die ukrainischen soldaten aber
auch in der ukrainischen bevölkerung ab
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
man sagt wir können das nicht dauerhaft
gewinnen aber das gegenteil ist der fall
also die ukraine ist entschlossen und
sie wird weiterhin verteidigen ganz egal
auch was die westlichen staaten machen
ob sie jetzt viele waffen oder weniger
öffentlich ich glaube da ist die ukraine
irland selbst verteidigt ich glaube da
haben auch sie nichts dagegen frau
wagenknecht das war logisch also ich
meine natürlich wollen nach meinem
empfinden also sie waren dort aber ich
zumindest was ich hier als gesprächen
entnommen hat natürlich wollen die
übergroße mehrheit der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer jetzt nicht unter russischer
oberherrschaft leben und ich glaube das
wäre ja auch dann tatsächlich eine
unterwerfung frieden aber ein kompromiss
wäre ja das was man eben zum beispiel in
istanbul so in den groben linien schon
mal ausgehandelt hatte also neutralität
gegen sicherheitsgarantien verzicht auf
die perspektive einer
nato-mitgliedschaft und eben spezieller
status don was und grimmen und wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel
also ich bin auch kein kreml astrologen
ich weiß nicht was in putins kopf
vorgeht aber ich höre ja das was er sagt
und ich sehe einen großen unterschied
zwischen seiner rede direkt am anfang
des krieges die tatsächlich diesen
brutalen nationalismus enthielt wo er
gesagt hat als die ukraine hat gar kein
existenzrecht und dem was er zum
beispiel jetzt am 9 mai gesagt das war
sehr defensiv und meines erachtens wäre
die russische führung also wenn sie
irgendwie rational ist und ich glaube
das ist schon noch dass putin möglichst
ich denke dass er froh ist wenn er jetzt
einen gesichtswahrenden ausweg hat also
weil der krieg ja eben nicht so gelaufen
ist wie sie das gedacht haben ob es von
vornherein jetzt wirklich um eine solche
unterwerfung überhaupt gegen weiß ich
nicht ich meine man muss natürlich auch
sehen krieg führende politiker sagen
selten worum es in dem krieg wirklich
geht also als die usa in den usa im irak
eingefallen ist haben sie auch nicht
gesagt es geht ums öl sondern sie haben
gesagt es geht um
massenvernichtungswaffen die wir
vernichten wollen obwohl sie gar nicht
gab und ich würde dienst damalige rede
wo er also wirklich in villa weise
gesagt hat die ukraine hat überhaupt
kein existenzrecht ich glaube das war
auch ans eigene volk er musste ja
irgendwie versuchen die menschen
mitzunehmen aber ob das jetzt wirklich
das kriegsziel war weiß ich nicht
zumindest glaub ich ist es jetzt nicht
mehr das kriegs iva ist völlig
unrealistisch wäre völlig unrealistisch
und aber was realistisch wäre wäre eben
ein solcher verhandlung skurrile und
meines wissens das war in der presse
also die washington post hat das
geschrieben auch der guardian ist das
gescheitert dieses verhandlungs diese
verhandlungsoptionen nicht daran dass
die russen nein gesagt haben sondern
dass die ukraine sich von dieser von
diesem zugeständnis
bezogen auf einen verzicht auf die
nato-mitgliedschaft wieder zurückgezogen
haben nachdem öffentlich zum beispiel
boris johnson ja seelands gerüffelt hat
der hat ja gesagt was macht ihr hier für
kompromisse findet er nicht gut und aus
amerikanischer seite kamen auch
ziemliche kritiken und da muss man jetzt
sehen da sind wieder ganz spezielle
interessen der beiden will seine wahlen
gewinn im november da muss er jetzt
sozusagen irgendwie als als kriegsheld
dastehen und nicht als soll mann der da
einen kompromiss waren das sind aber
alles dinge die eigentlich keine rolle
spielen dürfen wenn es darum geht diesen
furchtbaren krieg zu beenden wenn sie
jetzt damit anfangen sozusagen die usa
verantwortlich dafür zu machen und zu
sagen haben
druck gemacht dass es am ende so zu
sagen darum gehe dass es dort in
politische kämpfe zu gewinnen gibt also
das halte ich für ziemlich grossen
blödsinn muss ich sagen denn wenn wir
uns anschauen wie joe biden zu beginn
des krieges und davor ja alles versucht
hat auch mit putin zu sprechen es gab ja
diese gespräche olaf scholz ist nach
moskau gereist alle haben es ja versucht
vor dem krieg also vor dem 24 februar
und wenn wir uns die situation dort bei
den verhandlungen anschauen dann muss
man ja sagen dass wladimir putin hatte
sich zumindest gezeigt zu keinem
zeitpunkt ein interesse hatte als ist
noch um istanbul gegen dort einen
frieden zu erlangen weil die hatten doch
die hatten meines wissens ein dokument
über einen waffenstillstand wo dann
zumindest die russische seite sich
beschwert hat dass die ukraine von
dingen die sich schon zugesagt hatten
sich wieder zurückgenommen haben zum
beispiel eben diese und sich die leute
nein ich glaube aber zum beispiel ein
bericht der washington post am 5 april
die genau das gleiche berichtet hat die
nur eben dazu noch gesagt hat das ist
der einfluss namen gab von der nato auf
selensky dass er diese kompromisse nicht
machen soll so und wenn ich jetzt können
sie natürlich auch sagen die washington
post ist auch von putin gesteuert glaube
ich nicht also ich merke also man merkt
doch es gab doch ein strategiewechsel im
westen also ich glaube das können sie
doch auch nicht bestreiten es gab nach
diesem treffen in ramstein wo sie sie
alle zusammengesetzt haben zum glück
einen deutlichen strategiewechsel mann
hatte zunächst das gefühl auch die
europäer zumindest haben doch eher druck
gemacht einen schnellen frieden einen
kompromiss zu finden
und ab da wurde ganz klar in der
kommunikation auf einen langen krieg
orientiert es wurde gesagt wir liefern
jetzt ganz viel waffen und als
kriegsziel wurde ausgegeben wir müssen
russland in die knie zwingen wir müssen
russland maximal schwächen aber ehrlich
gesagt es muss doch darum gehen den
krieg sowohl das vokabular in die knie
aber ja aber das worden na ja aber das
ist ja sozusagen ein vokabular
es ist aber nicht also so machen sie
aber so wie sie sprechen sozusagen putin
zum opfer der arme putin muss ja auch
nicht sagt schwierigen lage herauskommen
der arme präsident dass er zumindest ein
bisschen von der ukraine bekommt weil er
nicht bekommen hat und deswegen soll er
jetzt irgendwie teile des ostens
bekommen also das halte ich für höchst
problematisch dass wir immer noch in
dieser weise über wladimir putin
diskutieren und wir müssen ja einmal
zurückgehen an dem beginn des krieges wo
sicherheitsexperten militärberater die
gesamte westliche welt eigentlich gesagt
hat weil man gedacht hatte dass die
russische armee so stark ist dass man
eben innerhalb von wenigen tagen in kiew
ist so als die ukraine sich so
heldenhaft verteidigt haben und es klar
war dass diese armee sei wohl eine
chance hat in der ukraine und dass es
nicht funktioniert keine chance dann
naja ihr land zu verteidigen ja aber
doch nicht da also dazu den krieg
militärisch für sich zu entscheiden das
ist doch eine illusion hat ist sein sohn
noch einmal kiew wo er über eine
atommacht gehen ja im zweifel frau eins
nach dem anderen sie sagen immer man
kann diesen krieg nicht militärisch
lösen noch einmal in kiew wurde die
russische armee zurückgedrängt wurde ist
der moment da wurde das wurde da gab es
eine militärische lösung genauso
schlecht sie haben sich um kopie etwa 30
da sind weil sie das fahrrad weil sie
sich verrechnet sie haben sich also
mächtig sind sie sind abgezogen weil sie
sich dann eben
bayerische lösung also wir sehen jeden
tag aber das war keine situation wo die
russen alles mobilisiert haben was sie
an militärischen kapazitäten haben
sondern sie haben sich dann weil ihr
konzept nicht aufgegangen ist das stimmt
sie hatten eine andere vorstellung was
sie dort machen haben sie sich dann
umgruppiert aber das war keine situation
wo sie ihre militärischen möglichkeiten
ausgereizt haben und ich mein normal es
geht nicht darum dass ich mitleid mit
putin habe ich finde diesen krieg
verbrecherisch sowie jeden krieg der in
den letzten 20 30 jahren oder überhaupt
jeden krieg verbrecherisch finde also
das ist überhaupt nicht meine intention
die frage ist ja nur wie man damit
umgeht dass russland eine atommacht ist
und wie man verhindert dass aus diesen
krieg in der ukraine ein großer krieg in
ganz europa wird wo wir dann auch ein
drin einbezogen sind ist er also
wirklich auch atomare
eskalationspotenzial hat und das möchte
ich nicht und deswegen finde ich muss
man sie soll auch kinder geben was ich
angst vor der erwartung vor auch eine
falsche alternative ergeben der verzicht
auf eine nato mitgliedschaft ist kein
ergeben sondern das wäre einer wirklich
gravierend wenn man sich wenn man im ort
teilweise abgibt also ein sonderstatus
heißt ja noch nicht dass jetzt der don
was irgendwie zu russland gehört im
minsker abkommen war auch ein
sonderstatus für den dorsch vereinbar
das hat mit repression zum beispiel soll
bereits der rubel eingeführt werden da
sonst eine abstimmung geben also das ist
eine art ist da was sie da verhandelt
haben da war glaube ich nicht davon die
rede dass der rubel 1 geführt aber das
aber wir reden ja darüber was jetzt
passiert und da ist es so dass in diesen
städten bereits darüber gesprochen wird
dass es dann eine abstimmung über einen
möglichen anschluss geben soll
verhandelt wird russland klar dass
senora schaffen sagt schaffen deswegen
muss man verhandeln und da muss man
solche fragen auf den tisch legen und
muss man gucken dass man einen
kompromiss findet aber nochmal dem was
der presse zu entnehmen war war das was
dort verhandelt wurde mit russland
abgestimmt die hätten das gemacht
nachdem was man gelesen hat oder
zumindest war es ein weg zu einem
waffenstillstand wo nicht die russen
gesagt haben wir ziehen uns zurück
sondern die ukraine haben gesagt die
zugeständnisse die sind wieder die die
nehmen wir vom tisch so und das finde
ich falsch und ich finde man hat dadurch
den krieg willkürlich verlängert und
aktuell finde ich das große problem dass
man gar nicht mehr versucht zu
verhandelt man versucht ist doch gar
nicht ich meine wenn es scheitert weil
putin nicht bereit ist verwandelt
das stimmt einfach nicht ich habe wenige
tage nach butter als es diese
kriegsverbrechen dort gab wo menschen
abgeschlachtet wurden auf den straßen
saß mir der präsident der ukraine
gegenüber und ich habe in frage gestellt
und habe gefragt also lenski können sie
angesichts dieser bilder in butter wo so
viele zivilisten abgeschlachtet wurden
noch mit putin an einem tisch sitzen
werden sie bereits zu verhandeln und er
hat gesagt natürlich wäre ich bereit zu
verhandeln aber wladimir putin erkennt
ja nicht mal würde mir so lenski als dem
präsidenten
der ukraine haben wir vielleicht ist das
format das erstmal delegation war
verhandelt sowie in istanbul gar nicht
so schlecht also wenn die zwei
miteinander verhandeln dann geht es ja
nur wieder darum dass jeder dort also
als der sieger rausgeht das ist aber
nicht ein sinnvoller eine sinnvolle
voraussetzung deswegen wenn es
verhandlungen gäbe wäre es schon
sinnvoll dass das erst mal so zu sagen
leute vertreter machen und meine sorge
ich finde wir als westliche staaten
haben auch eine verantwortung uns dafür
einzusetzen dass es wieder verhandlungen
gibt und nicht das zu tun was damals
passierte seelands hier unter druck zu
setzen dass er keine kompromisse